the amount of people in here that have a
job they hate and they buy things they
don't care about to impress people
[Music]
the question is what so it's a really
interesting question and as I was
listening and I hope people paying
attention most people spend money on
dumb things which then forces them to do
things they don't want so step number
one for most people in here they should
sell their home take the money and go
rent they should return their BMW and
get a Toyota
and that's why and honestly that becomes
the vulnerability why do you want to BMW
[Music]
so to me that's where it gets
interesting
right do you or do you like what the
brand does to make you look to other
people I don't know I'm not assuming I
don't know I know I have a point I don't
know you but I know in the macro that
98% of people that buy a Mercedes or BMW
likes what it makes other people think
of them and not that they like it and
that 487 dollars a month versus what
they really need which is a hundred
dollars a month is why they have a job
they hate because they're paying for a
life that means nothing
[Music]
you that have a job they hate and they
buy things they don't care about to
impress people they will give a [ __ ]
about scares the [ __ ]
[Music]